so und wieder muss ein Flut Versager
seinen Posten räumen mehr als ein Jahr
nach dieser Flutkatastrophe im Ahrtal
tritt Roger lewenz der
rheinland-pfälzische Innenminister jetzt
zurück der Vorwurf er habe diese
Katastrophe verpennt und da geht's vor
allem um ein Video aus einem
Polizeihubschrauber dieses hier nämlich
der Heli ist in den ersten Stunden der
Katastrophe über das Ahrtal geflogen hat
eben dieses Video in die Leitzentralen
geschickt ja und spätestens dann hätte
ja die Hilfe mit voller Kraft anlaufen
müssen ist sie aber eben nicht levens
hatte nämlich behauptet selbst auf
diesem Video habe man keine akute
Notlage erkennen können
[Musik]